now let's look at the very very lost pot
how are they gonna ask us to use this
result it says for how many months after
retirement will there be money left in
the account for how many months after a
time it will there be money left in the
account so I want you to help me just to
work out what our trajectory through the
rest of the question is what are you
gonna do with this expression in order
to find out how long the money's going
to last
does anyone where you started it yeah
Michael when a of N equals zero that
means everything's gone right just like
in another situation the loan is repaid
or for this it means we hope his family
has some other kind of income stream
because got nothing left in his in his
bank account okay now don't forget more
likely than not at the bottom here
you're going to get a decimal of some
kind right so say for example just gonna
make up a number let's suppose it was
seventeen point three I really hope it's
a lot longer than that but let's just
imagine okay
it was seventeen point three when you
were solving for n what conclusion would
you draw from the question for how many
months after a timer will there be money
left in the account I'm gonna let you
think about that one dealing with this
final step is a really crucial part it's
why there are so many marks there are
three marks on this right oh it's only
two that's disappointing it should be
three
yeah I know I was trying not to ruin the
answer if it was this I want you to
think really carefully about whether it
would be seventeen or whether it would
be eighteen what makes sense in the
question will there be money for this
less or this more which way should you
round I want you to think really hard
about how money is coming out you could
test some values if you like once you
get the real answer which which is
thankfully a lot more than this okay
how long will actually mean money left
in there if you've got an answer call
mrs. Lee's driver and we'll check out
your working it's a lot of people say to
get to an answer which is great so I
want to interpret that answer with you
yeah he should be the number that you
get it was that right yes okay a hundred
thirty four point one four so what is
his main is the answer one hundred
seventy four which is what this would
round closest to you or 175 hmm it's
always refreshing when you get the right
number right it's a relief
the answer is 175 but the question is
why and knowing why really comes back to
the wording of the question so read it
one more time with me
it says for how many months after a
timer will there be money left in the
account how many months will there be
money left in the account okay so what
does this 174 point one four represent
it means how many months he makes that
two thousand dollar withdrawal right so
in the one hundred and seventy fourth
month
what's that fifteen years ish something
like that yeah okay after all these
years in the 174th month he takes out
the two thousand dollars head he as he
always has been doing right and then in
135th month he can't take out a full
what of two thousand anymore I don't
know maybe a few hundred bucks left in
there but according to the wording of
the question there is still money left
in the account a teeny bit not enough
for a full withdrawal but there's still
something near okay we can reword this
question such at the answer would not be
a hundred seventy-five we can reword it
slightly to make it one seventy four for
instance if the question said for how
many months can he make his withdrawal
of two thousand dollars make his full
withdrawal
well now you interpret the question
differently right or rather you
interpret your answer differently so
what I'm trying to emphasize to you here
is how important reading the words of
the question are from knowing when do
you make the withdrawal or when is the
interest applied to what on earth do I
do with this number does it go up or
does it go down it's all about
interpreting the language okay which is
part of why we sort of left this part of
the topic off to one side so that you
would get all of the formulas down which
is what the susan sequences you did last
year was about and now it's all about
using an actual
situations okay